everyone needs a vacation that's for
sure but here's the advice if you're
gonna take
a vacation this is also an article from
cnbc they said
use your points and miles asap
says a credit analyst and here's how to
get the most
out of them with millions of people
sitting on points that they couldn't
spend last year
plus new ones they've earned from the
pandemic era promotions
airlines and credit card companies are
likely to devalue their points
in the next few months experts say so
save that money and spend those points
you don't want to get you know
nothing's free these days so you know
take a deal when you got it
so here's a little background a little
context for years
airlines have been moving the goal posts
on how many points it takes for
travelers to redeem their rewards
you ever traveled on points before no
you've ever traveled on points
yep it's a beautiful thing it's free
essentially you pay maybe a little fee
but
it's an awesome thing so basically
here's what the airlines have been doing
so first they stopped tying points so
the number of miles
a passenger has traveled and instead
they started basing them around
the amount the passengers paid for the
airfare okay so then they started
requiring more points to take a free
flight
so this credit expert says to consider
these tips to get the most out of your
points number one
book flights as soon as you can to avoid
the price bumps and fee hikes from
increased demand
supply and demand that's economics 101
supply and demand a lot of people are
going to be traveling
a lot of people are booking flights
sooner you can get your flight book the
better the more you'll save
number two compare the total cost
of the air travel compare your total
cost before booking airfare basic
economy
is usually the cheapest fares we know
that but an inexpensive award fare might
end up costing more in the end because
all the restrictions
and add-on fees i.e luggage
seats you know fees like that so
you know they said there's certain
things in life death taxes
airline fees you can include that as
well um and then last but not least fly
routes are feeling the loss of
business travel you know business travel
they might say might never come back
nobody's traveling for business days
just get on a zoom meeting right right
exactly
because business travel will most likely
not be returning this summer routes that
depend on corporate travelers will have
some of the lowest rates that's why a
lot of new york travel or san francisco
travel is probably pretty cheap because
that's a lot of business travel
consider traveling to the big cities
that would traditionally be
business hot spots especially
international destinations
so use your credit
card points asap if you enjoyed that
short clip from the sawzcast
click here to watch another click here
to watch the full episode
or just stay broke